tell me about your outfits were both
very different yes and mines based on
the animated series and I actually
bought the mask and I did actually buy
the dress I was going to make one but
failure at sewing I'm afraid and the the
prop the mallet I've actually made
myself and this is just foam yoga mats
rolled together glued and acrylic paint
and then just glossed over with PVA and
and then this is actually just a mop and
just something my dad gave me at the
bottom it's it's do with on piping but
you can't just use like I'm you know the
walking stick things you can just use
that but he had that on hand and wig
both of the internet and she's costumed
we're then within their paint leather
pane and yeah that's basically really
I'm living it brilliant and how about
you I based my costume on the first game
aftermath eylem I kind of wanted to make
it my own that's why I don't have her
exact costume I spend about half a year
getting all of this together and it's my
real hair so that's always nice boots
are just literally tights over long
shoes so you know going simple but well
it's good you're looking great well
obviously made a really good effort
living the yoga mat Hammer fantastic
idea before we go any top tips anyone
who wants to take part in cosplay
themselves and maybe not done it before
don't be afraid to do whatever you want
dress up as whatever you want be whoever
you want it's about not being new it's
about doing what you want to do so just
have fun do you not pressure yourself
too much and before I came to this
convention Friday I was so nervous and
nobody seems to judge you everyone
seemed so friendly and I am actually
someone who suffers with anxiety and I'm
agoraphobia and I saved people like that
really it's not that bad because we're
all the same we're all nervous and
that's basically my best advice
no fantastic did a great job
you